coral is not only an organism it is an
ecosystem a host to a wide variety of
organisms it is what we call a symbiote
in order to better understand the coral
sim biome we use confocal microscopy
which allows us to observe the living
Carl in a non-invasive manner much can
be learned from these observations
including a signature and distribution
of innate fluorophores the distribution
and fluorescent and mission of
endosymbiotic algae and the presence and
characterization of coral larvae and
associated a performer therefore we can
look at the Carl and all associated
organisms as a whole and living entity
here only the innate fluorescence of the
coral itself and its associated
organisms is imaged no dyes or
fluorescent labels are used the bright
red coloring of this healthy coral is
due to the fluorescence of chlorophyll
contained in the end of symbiotic algae
known as symbiodinium these unicellular
organisms provide the Carl with first
synthetic nutrients and the coral in
return provides them with necessary
inorganic materials the blue and green
colors represent the corals own
fluorescent proteins time-lapse imaging
shows as the movement of the polyps and
the tissues that surround the polyps
known as the sea nasaan if you look
closely you can see tiny rotifers
calling on the surface of call
confocal microscopy can give
high-resolution images by eliminating
light from outside of the focal plane
layers of data from different focal
planes known as Z stacks can be
collected and reassembled into
three-dimensional images confocal images
can clearly show the distribution of
different fluorophores individual red
dots of symbiodinium can be seen the
tentacles and throughout the Cena Sark
the fluorescent protein represented by
the blue color in this Carl seems to be
closely associated with biological
structures containing the masses or
stinging cells using the confocal
microscope also allows us to see inside
the car such as this view of the lace
coral polyps gastrovascular canal a side
view through this polyps tentacles shows
us the densely packed symbiodinium and
bands of tissue that bind the tentacles
together in a close-up view of coral
tissue we can see the arrangement of
symbiodinium and the green fluorescence
of individual coral sounds as docile as
Carl may appear they are actually very
dynamic aside from moving tentacles they
can extend these material filaments from
their mouths in this image combining
fluorescence and transmitted light you
can see the Me's material filaments
moving inside the mouth of this pollen
corals use the extrusion of material
filaments to battle with neighboring
Carl to catch prey or in this case to
expel symbiodinium another important
aspect of studying the Carlson Bayern is
to identify its associated a performer
this species of rotifer is one we often
find when looking at lace Carl this one
has a red fluorescing organelle possibly
from ingesting chlorophyll containing
phytoplankton the coral symbol often
includes larvae particularly if the
larvae are brooded meaning retained by
the maternal polyp until they reach a
more mature larval stage when la vie are
ready to find a suitable substrate for
settlement a stage known as plan EULA
they use cilia to move themselves
through the water
here are a few examples of other species
of coral under confocal
coral reefs are among the most
threatened ecosystems on earth as
temperature rises corals lose their
endosymbionts leaving them in a severely
weakened state this process is known as
coral bleaching in order to reverse the
global decline of our lives we need a
greater understanding of the differences
between species and the interactions
between the Carl their endosymbionts and
associated at the corner
you